if you were to ask me what I'm
passionate about I would probably say
something like physics or even science
communication I would have written that
down several times on something like a
scholarship application or even just
given it as a response when someone
asked me about what I do
but I think a lot of the ideas around
finding your passion are very flawed so
by all accounts I guess I'm a very
driven person I am self-motivated and
I'm interested in lots of things I like
to achieve things and I'm always working
on something I guess that's just part of
my personality and and what people see
of me is that I'm always sort of working
on little projects we're trying to get
things done so a friend from high school
recently said to me like Toby you are so
lucky to have found your passion and I
guess that really got me thinking like
am i lucky like is this really a
privileged position that I wanted to
have found my passion because I don't
really see it that way and if we're
talking about my passion as being
science I don't think that's something
that you know I was born with as a given
passion I think that it's something I
chose it's something that I chose to be
interested in and I chose to pursue and
and do things in that area so when my
friend said that I was lucky to have
found my passion she was feeling a lot
more down that she didn't really have
anything that she knew she was really
interested in above anything else um she
felt like she didn't have anything that
she was passionate about and that's I
guess a really hard position to be and
to feel like I guess there's something
wrong with you if you don't have you
know one career direction that you
should be moving in and to her someone
like me seems to have that very clear
direction and a very definite path to
follow but that's not the way that I
feel yes I've done a lot of stuff within
physics and science now but it started
off as just an interest and you know
that aspects of passion grew around just
the years of study and if it I've put
into developing this interest in
something
and that's led it to become almost part
of my identity and my personality is
that I'm really into science stuff but I
don't think you know I was born with
some destiny to become a scientist I
just was interested in something and
chose to make it the path I was going to
go down I think that your passion is
really just a mindset and to be honest
if physics my passion was to just be
deleted from the world one day just gone
and I had no longer anything to do with
it because it was just gone I would be
okay with that
I'm pretty confident that I would have
found something else that I was
interested in that I would have put
effort into and pursued and that would
be my new passion
I've got interests and a lot of
different things like I said I guess
that's one aspect of my personality that
I easily find things interesting so if
I'd never gone and studied physics I
think right now maybe I'd be doing a PhD
in something like psychology or a field
like that and I'd be happy with that
that would be my passion and I'd wrap my
existence around that new thing I I
don't think there's anything special
about physics it's just the thing that I
happened to have chosen in this version
of reality I guess one thing that was
holding my friend back from pursuing
things a bit more was that she felt like
she hadn't been lucky enough to just be
handed a passion but I think another
aspect of it is a fear of failure so the
same person said to me that they do fear
trying new things because they do have a
fear of failure and that's really common
it is tied up with a lot of insecurities
about everything and it can really
prevent you from trying new things and
from selecting an interest to become
your passion for example I've never
thought that I was the best at something
like physics I never thought that I was
the very best at it and even something
like making videos for YouTube I look
back at videos that only made a week ago
and will cringe at them but you know if
I was waiting to feel really secure
about everything that I did and
everything that I made I would never
have made a single video ever and it's
likewise I probably would never have
pursued physics
I allowed myself to be afraid of not
being as good as someone else I guess
what I did was just accepted that
there's a transition of trying and not
being so great at something and I was
able to find a mindset where that didn't
bother me I can't say that I've always
been able to find that mindset like I've
had things that I was insecure about
that I did let consume me sometimes but
I saw the importance of finding that
mindset where you aren't afraid of
failure because I guess if you're going
to try and pull yourself out of that
spot where nothing interests you you
have no passions and you don't know how
to find one because just nothing is
interesting I guess it's all about
trying to overcome the fear of failure
and trying new things trying skill-based
activities and developing your skills
and them passions are all about the
situation you've been placed in
throughout your childhood the activities
you've tried and the things that you've
just been able to have a go at and
develop skills in because once you
develop skills and something and you
start to become good at it I think it
naturally makes you like that thing more
and that might develop them to the one
thing that you would call your passion I
think a passion really just means the
thing that you do the most and often
that's something you're good at
something that you're trying out
something you're trying to become better
in I do think that I am lucky in a way
thinking back to the comment that my
friend made but not lucky to have found
my passion I still don't believe that
you know there's any God giving up
passions or gifts when you're born it's
not like each human has some passion
deep down in their code that you have to
unearth it's just the places that we
fall into I do feel lucky that I had a
mindset where I found things interesting
and that has defined Who I am is to find
the fact that when trying to select
something to pursue I felt like I had
multiple options and if one of them was
to go away like physics the citizen
disappear I would be just fine with that
in fact I often think about the version
of myself
that did pursue something different like
psychology or philosophy like those are
some of the other things I'm interested
in and you know I would have just put
all my effort into that other thing so I
do feel lucky in that way and I guess my
advice if you don't feel like you have
that ability to find lots of things
interesting is to just try as many skill
based activities as you can so for that
reason I am happy to have this video
supported by Skillshare school chair is
a place where you can develop your skill
based interests through classes on
things like design innovation and
technology for my audience I would
recommend some courses on Python
including this one for data science and
machine learning and this one covering
the basics of Python programming I do
have a special link where my viewers can
get two months of unlimited access to
Skillshare for free so I'll put that
link on the screen and down in the
description I'd really encourage you to
check it out because they have over
20,000 courses and I'm sure you can find
one there to try and develop some of
your own skill based interests and start
learning so thank you guys for watching
this video and I'll see you next time